[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واتقبل الله صومكم اهلا بكم
في حصاد الليله معكم محمد كريشان في هذه
اللحظات عواصم ومدن في العالم تعيش
اجوائها الخاصه هذه اللقطات من اوتوا
الكنديه والتي يزورها الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدون في زياره هي الاولى لرئيسنا امريكي
منذ اربعه عشر عاما
اما هذه اللقطات فتاتينا من مكه المكرمه
واجواء الحرم في شهر رمضان بوعيده انتهاء
صلاه التراويح
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصيد امريكي ايراني في الساحه السوريه بعد
مقتل متعاقد امريكي واصابه اخر الى جانب
خمسه جنود ضربات متبادله بين القوات
الامريكيه وجماعات مرتبطه بالحرس الثوري
في دير الزور والحسكه مسؤولون امريكيون
يقولون ان تحقيق جاري بعد تعثر عمل
منظومات الدفاع بكامل طاقتها واتصال بين
رئيس الاركان الامريكي ونظيره الاسرائيلي
لبحث المواجهه مع ايران في الاقليم
احتجاجات مستمره ضد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعد اصرارها على اجراء تعديلات في النظام
القضائي
عقب تحضير رئيس الاركان لنتنياهو تاثير
الاضطرابات على جاهزيه الجيش لاي تطورات
امنيه عدوى احتجاجات تنتشر داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه مع لاني عشرات الطيارين واكثر من
مئه من قوات النخبه امتناعهم عن الالتحاق
بقواعدهم
بعد الحديث عن استعداد الاوكراني لشن هجوم
مضاد في باك مود مسؤولون امريكيون يقولون
ان كيف قد تسعى في هجوم المرتقب لقطع
الجسر الواصل بين روسيا والقرم ومع
استمرار الغرب في حشد الدعم توافق اوروبي
على توفير مساعدات جديده تتضمن مليون
قذيفه مدفعيه وذخيره وصواريخ وموسكو تحذر
بان الخبراء الاجانب هدف مشروع لقواتها
مع استمرار الخلاف الاثيوبي المصري
السوداني الذي سببه تعلن اكتمال بناء سد
النهضه بنسبه 90% والقاهره تحذر من خطر
وجودي يطال 150 مليون شخص وتصف عمليات
البناء والمال بانها خرق للقانون الدولي
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم الازمه بين حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو وهي ازمه مستمره مع
الاحتجاجات الرافضه للتعديلات القضائيه
خصوصا بعد اتساعها داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
اذ ابلغ عشرات الطيارين في قوات الاحتياط
واكثر من مئه جندي من عناصر النخبه بوحده
الاستخبارات ابلغوا قادتهم بالامتناع عن
الالتحاق بقواعدهم ياتي ذلك بعد تحذير
رئيس الاركان لنتنياهو من مخاطر ما يجري
وان ذلك من شانه ان يمس بجهزيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لاي تطورات امريه والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي هل تؤدي لاحتجاجات
لشرخ بين المؤسسه العسكريه وحكومه نتنياهو
النتائج جاءت كالتالي
65% صوتوا بنعم بينما صوت 35% لصالح عدم
حدوث شرخ بين المؤسسه العسكريه وحكومه
نتيجه لهذه الاحتجاجات
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
التطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في اثيوبيا موجات الجفاف تعصف بمجتمعات
الراي
[موسيقى]
فساحه السوريه اشتباكنا امريكي ايراني
تقول واشنطن ان مجموعه مرتبطه بالحرس
الثوريه الايراني استهدفت بمسيره منشاه
يتمركز فيها جنودا جنودا امريكيون في
منطقه الحسكه والحصيره كانت مقتله متعاقده
امريكي واصابه سته ام خمسه جنود ومتعاقد
اخر فيما قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان تحقيقا
جاريا لمعرفه السبب وراء عدم استجابه
منظومات الدفاع في القاعده التي تمت
مهاجمتها في الرد اكد البانداغون ان
الطائره المسيره التي نفذت الهجوم ايرانيه
وان الرد عليه كان باستهداف منشاتين
لفصائل تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني في
سوريا وبالتزامن مع الحديث عن هذا الهجوم
يعلن ان اتصالا اجري بين قائد هيئه
الاركان المشتركه للقوات الامريكيه
الجنرال مارك ميلي ونظيره الاسرائيلي
كانت ايران في صلبه
هجوم بطائره مسيره على موقع للقوات
الامريكيه في سوريا وتحديدا في منطقه
الحسكه يؤدي الى مقتل متعقد امريكي واصابه
خمسه جنود لم يتاخر الرد الامريكي سلاح
الجو يستهدف منشات تابعه لجماعات مرتبطه
بالحرس الثوري الايراني في دير الزور
القصف الامريكي وفق مصادر محليه تسبب في
مقتل عدد من الاشخاص في حي هرابش الذي
تتمركز فيه قوات للحرس الثوري الايراني
قرب المطار العسكري في دير الزور
الرد والرد المضاد استمر كما يبدو لعده
جولات فالقوات المواليه لايران في المنطقه
ضربت قاعده التحالف الدولي في حقل العمر
شرق دير الزور وسط نفي امريكي لوقوع قتله
وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي تشهد فيها
سوريا استهدافات متبادله ثلاث قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه معلومه بشكل مؤكد وما بين
900 الى 2000 جندي امريكي يتمركزون حاليا
في سوريا في قاعده التنافس عند مثلث
الحدود الاردنيه العراقيه السوريه قاعده
حقل العمر النفطي في دير الزور قاعده
الرميلان في الحسكه اما المجموعات
المواليه لايران فيمكن الحديث عن تمركز
واضح المعالم في العاصمه دمشق ومطارها
ومناطق في ريفها وحلب ومطار النيرب في
المدينه اضافه الى وجود في حمص وعند اكثر
من موقع قرب الحدود مع العراق للاشراف على
خطوط الامداد العسكريه عبر ما عبر رسميه
وغير رسم
وبحسب الجانب الامريكي نفذت الجماعات
المدعومه من ايران نحو 78 هجوما على قوات
التحالف بسوريا منذ عام
وتنوعت وسائل الهجوم بين مسيرات ملغمه
وصواريخ وقذائفها وفي وقت تقول واشنطن
انها تستهدف بين الحين والاخر مجموعه
مدعومه من ايران ما يلفت الى حدوث
استهدافات تبقى خارج اطار التبني الرسمي
وهو ما قد يشير الى لاعب اخر وهو اسرائيل
بحسب الاتهامات الصادره من ايران وكذلك من
النظام السوري
[موسيقى]
وتعليقا على الهجوم قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض جون كيربي ان الغارات التي شنتها
بلاده في سوريا كانت تهدف الى حمايه
القوات الامريكيه مضيفا في مقابله مع شبكه
سي ان ان انتشار القوات الامريكيه في
سوريا يركز على محاربه تنظيم الدوله متهما
مجموعات وصفها بالمدعومه من ايران بشن
هجمات على المنشات الامريكيه في سوريا
الاجراءات التي اتخذناها بالامس هي جزء من
جهودنا لحمايه قواتنا ومنشاتنا البيئه
الحاليه خطيره ونحن هناك لالحاق الهزيمه
بتنظيم الدوله الذي لا يزال يشكل تهديدا
في سوريا والعراق ويخطط ويجري تدريبات ومن
الواضح انه قادر على شان عمليات هناك ايضا
مجموعه مسلحه مدعومه من ايران وهي التي
تشن هذه الهجمات ضد قواتنا وسنواصل
القيامه بكل ما في وسعنا لدفاع عن انفسنا
والرد عليها كما فعلنا بالامس
ان الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى صراعا مع
ايران داعيا طهران الى عدم المشاركه في
دعم الهجمات على المنشات الامريكيه
ويؤسكم
لا نسعى لخوض حرب مع ايران ولا نبحث عن
نساء عن مسلح معها او حرب اخرى في المنطقه
نهدف الى حمايه قواتنا في سوريا في وجه
المجموعات المدعومه من ايران التي توفر
التدريب والموارد الحرس الثوري الايراني
منشات في سوريا يتم فيها توفير الكثير من
الموارد وكان بعض هذه المواقع هدفا للقصف
الاخير
معنا الان من واشنطن كبير الباحثين في
معهد سوفان للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامن
الدولي والمستشار السابق في الكونجرس
لشؤون ايران والخليج ومن طهران عباس خميار
الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه السابق اهلا
بضيفينا نبدا بضيفنا الامريكي والسؤال عما
اذا كانت
واشنطن الان تتحاور مع طهران عسكريا بعد
تعذر الحوار السياسي بخصوص الملف النووي
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافتي هذا في الحقيقه ليس
بالشيء الجديد فقد حصلت صدامات سابقا وحصل
قوات منشات مدعومه من قبل الحرس الثوري
الايراني بالهجوم علينا احيانا هذه المره
هجموا شمالا مره اخرى هجموا عن منطقه
النتف ولكن انت هذه هذا الهجوم وهذه
المصادمات ليست امرا ليس لا سابقه له بل
انه الولايات المتحده كانت اصطدام مع
مجموعه اكبر تدعمها روسيا قبل سنه حوالي
وضمه ودمرت
ودمرت والحقت
الروسيه هناك وبالتالي هذا ليس بالامر
الغريب واملاك طبعا هذا يعني هناك مزيد من
التوتر في المنطقه لان ايران تزيد تقصيبها
للرانيوم
وبالتالي كما انها ما تزال ناشطه جدا في
المنطقه ولكن طبعا هذا يعجب التراجع ذلك
لان التي بعد اتفاق بين السعوديه وايران
لتخفيض التوتر ربما كان هناك توقعات ان
ايران
تحتوي او توقف بعض القوات وان الحرث ثوري
سيهدا قليلا ويقلل نشاطاته ولكنه الان هذا
هذا الحادث
يزيد اشعال النار التوترات التي كانت
توقعي انها ستنخفض بعد اتفاق الايراني
والسعودي اذا لم اذا لماذا لم تنخفض
الامور سيد
عباس خميار
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه تحيه لك
وللمشاهدين ورمضان كريم وكل عام وانتم
بالف خير الحقيقه تاتي هذه المناوشات
العسكريه ربما من موقع الضعف امريكي خاصه
بعد
العمليات المتسارعه التي نشاهدها في
المنطقه بعد الاتفاقيه
الصينيه السعوديه الايرانيه السعوديه هذا
ما نشاهده جيدا فيما يتعلق
برجوع سوريا او محاوله ارجاعها الى الحضن
العربي
واستقبالها في قمه رياض المرتقبه
مستقبلا اضافه الى ذلك الموقف الاسرائيلي
الذي اعتبر هذه الاتفاقيه بانها كارثه
للامريكان ولاسرائيل
وشاهدنا تداعيات هذه الاتفاقيه في
البرلمان الاردني وفي مناطق عندما طلب
البرلمانيون اخراج السفير الاسرائيلي من
عمان كل والموقف مجلس التعاون من هذه
الاتفاقيه نحن نعيش مرحله جديده هذه
المرحله تختلف عن السابقاتها والحقيقه هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذه المواقف وهذا التطبيع الذي
كان يطبل له على مدى السنوات الاخيره اصبح
من الماضي وما مات قبل ان يولد وكل هذه
وضعت واشنطن في حجر الزاويه اتصور هذه
ردود فعل امريكيه تجاه هذه الاتفاقيه
واتجاه هذه الهزيمه السياسيه بعد الهزائم
العسكريه التي بنيت بها في العراق وفي
افغانستان انا اريد ان اسال الامريكان
واسال ضيفك ماذا تعمل ماذا تعمل امريكا في
في شرق سوريا
كيف
بامكانه سيد سيد عباس خميار بامكانه ايضا
ان
يسال اي امريكي وماذا وماذا تفعل ايران
هنا هناك والقوات المواليه لها ايضا في
سوريا لو سمحت حتى اعود حتى حتى اسمحني
اسمح لي يا اخي اتفضل هذه اتفضل بسرعه
اتفضل هذه هذه قوات نعم هذه قوات السوريه
هذه قوات مدعوه من الحكومه الرسميه
السوريه التي تتفاوض معها الان السعوديه
وكل دول المنطقه وتريد ارجاعها الى
مكانتها القانونيه وهذا يختلف عن احتلال
وعمليه نهب للثروه السوريه من قبل
الامريكان اختلاف لو سمحت
سيد عباس فما اعود للضيفه الامريكي
التقديرات تقول الان السيد كاتزمان ان
يوجد في سوريا تقريبا 15 ,000 من
المقاتلين الموالين لايران بين عراقيين
وافغان وباكستانيين وغيرهم بينما لا يوجد
في سوريا الا 900 جندي امريكي هل هذا مربك
بالنسبه
للامريكيين كتوازن قوه في الساحه السوريه
كلا لا اعتقد انه موقف صعب
هؤلاء 1900 نعم هناك عقد واحد قتل على من
قبل هذه القوات المدعومه من حرس الثوري
لكن الولايات المتحده ردت على ذلك وقتها
11 ودمرت قاعدهتين
بجهد بسيط وضعت الولايات المتحده وبالتالي
اذا بدنا نكون حريصا تاريخيا عندما تحدث
عن ضعف امريكي لان السيد فتن اعتقد انه
الولايات المتحده الضعيفه فدخل اوكرانيا
والان ولايه المتحده تدمر كل قواته
العسكريه حتى دون التوجه الى هناك فقط
بتوفير الاسلحه للاوكرانيين القوات
الروسيه تدمر وبالتالي لابد ان نكون
الدقيقه وحريصا عندما استعمل مصطلح لو كنت
قائدا مسؤولا الايرانيين عندما عندما اقول
انه الولايات المتحده ضعيفه ان هذه فكره
ضعيفه جدا ان تمر في اذانك اذانهم والتحدي
ايران بالقول من يقول ذلك عاده ينتهي به
المطاف الى الاسف الشديد للتفكيرهم بهذه
الطريقه
السيد عباس قميار كلامك السابق يوحي بان
ايران تشعر بانها الان في وضع مريح
بتعويم حليفها بشار الاسد
وبتعثر التطبيع مع اسرائيل ولكن الا يبدو
هذا ربما بعض حسابات المغلوطه لان ايران
التطبيعها مع السعوديه او مع غيره لا يعني
ان لها حريه التصرف كما تريد في المنطقه
لا لا ايران هي
الازمات في المنطقه وكانت دائما تسير في
هذا الاتجاه ليس هو انتقاما لاحد او يعني
الموضوع يختلف هناك هزائم امريكيه واضحه
في المنطقه هناك
الازمات كانت مستعصيه ايران تستطيع مع
السعوديه ومع الدول الاخرى في المنطقه
تقوم بخطوات
الحقيقه
تصالحيه وحل هذه الازمات سوريا كانت
مستهدفه والجميع يعرفوا ذلك ماذا يعمل
الامريكان هناك ماذا تعمل القوه التكفيريه
التي جاءت من اكثر من ثمانين الدوله لكي
تسقط نظاما رسميا يعترف
شكرا لك سيد عباس خميار من طهران شكرا لك
سيد كنت كادز من من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
يتسعوا نطاق العصيان في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي احتجاجا على تعديل النظام
القضائي حيث ابلغ عشرات الطيارين في قوات
الاحتياط قادتهم وقف المشاركه في
التدريبات والامتناع عن الالتحاق بقواعدهم
كما ابلغ اكثر من 100 جندي من عناصر
النخبه بوحده الاستخبارات وزير الدفاع
بعدم الالتحاق بصفوف الاحتياط ضمن الوحدات
تاتي هذه التطورات بوعيده تحذير رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي من احتمال تاثير هذا
التطور على جهوزيه الجيش في التعامل مع اي
تطور امني
في مقابل اصرار معسكر اليمين بقياده
نتنياهو على تمرير التعديلات القضائيه
يتجند الشارع الاسرائيلي وخلفه طيف واسع
من المعارضه لرفضها لكنما كان يطفو على
السطح بشكل محتشم قبل اسابيع صار الان
الحدث الابرز في اسرائيل الجيش الاسرائيلي
قياده ومجندين واحتياطيين يتصدرون
المحتجين ويرفضون التعديلات القضائيه او
ما تصفه المعارضه بالانقلاب القضائي في
سلاح الجو عشره الطيارين يرفضون اداء
الخدمه العسكريه وجنود احتياط اخرون
يوقعون على عريضه مماثله وقبل هؤلاء عناصر
في مختلف فيالق وكتائب الجيش الاسرائيلي
بل توسع الامر ليشمل اجهزه المخابرات
مدنيها وعسكريها فهل يغير كل هذا من خطه
نتنياهو الراغب في ارضاء حلفائه المتدينين
المتزمتين والافلات من حبل المسائله
القضائيه الذي ما زال يهدده الاجابه حتى
الان لا فقد خرج بن يمينه ياهو ليخاطب
الاسرائيليين وقال انه عازم على المضي
قدما في طرح التعديلات التي تمس اربعه
بنود وتحد من قدره القضاء على مراقبه
قرارات الحكومه التي سيكون لها الاغلبيه
في لجان تعيين القضاه على الرغم من دخول
الولايات المتحده على الخط وتحذيرها من
تداعيات تمريرها على الجبهه الداخليه
لاسرائيل كلام نتنياهو جاء بعد اجتماع تم
الخميس التقى فيه رونينبار رئيس جهاز
الامن العام الاسرائيلي الشباك الذي حذر
من ان اسرائيل تنظيف طريق خطير للغايه
بوجود تهديدات الامنيه وتواصل الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه وقبله حذر وزير الدفاع من تداعيات
خطه التعديلات على الجيش ومؤسسه الدفاع
كما حذر الرئيس الاسرائيلي من تفكك الدوله
ان لم يتم التوصل الى توافق وتعود جذور
الخلاف الى كون المدافعين عن التعديلات من
طائفه متدينه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
تتكاثر ديموغرافيا بايقاع اسرع من باقي
الاسرائيليين لكنها لا تدفع الضرائب ولا
تخدم في الجيش ويتصدر الجيش ومجندوه جبهه
المعترين على التعديلات فهم يرون ان
التشريعات التي ستصدر من القضاء ستحد من
حريتهم لصالح طائفه من المجتمع لا تساهم
في امن ورخاء اسرائيل وهذه واحده من اكبر
نقاط الخلاف في المجتمع الاسرائيلي في
تاريخ القصير
[موسيقى]
معنى من الناصره محمود يسبك استاذ دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه حيفا اهلا وسهلا بك
ما سمي في اسرائيل بالانقلاب القضائي
لماذا بدا مستفزا للجيش
هو يعني مستفزه معنيا
ليس للجيش
العامل انما للقوى الاحتياط في الجيش التي
عمليا هي قوه من المجتمع المدني يعني
مواطنين عاديين ويدعون للخدمه العسكريه
بين الفينه الاخرى بشكل يعني متواصله او
حتى او في وقت الازمه ولكن الجيش كجيش
يعني لم نسمع حتى الان بانه هنالك حاله
التمرد واحده او هناك حاله رفض اي جندي
للخدمه العسكريه ما رايناه حتى الان وبشكل
متواضع انا اقول يعني الاعداد التي تحدث
عنها عشره هناك وعشرين هناك مائه هو نوع
هناك ولا تمثل قطاعات كبيره من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي التي ترفض الخدمه العسكريه
وعلى العكس من ذلك انا اعتقد باعتقادي ان
هنالك بلغ في تصوير هذا الرفض اللي من قبل
بعض جنود الاحتياط ان كانوا في الطيران او
كانوا في النخبه العسكريه ما يسمى لانه
بالنهايه يعني
الجندي الاسرائيلي ان كان في الخدمه
المتواصله او في الاحتياط هو لا يحترم شيء
يسمى حقوق انسان حينما يدعى
للقتال ونحن نذكر جيدا ما قام به هؤلاء
الطيارين الذين الان يعني وكانهم يحتجون
على سياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ما قاموا
به من انزال قنابل اطنان نعم ولكن حتى
نبقى في الموضوع بعد قطاع غزه نعم حتى
نبقى في الموضوع عندما يقول لبيذ بان
نتنياهو لم يستمع لوزير الدفاع وعندما
يقول وزير الدفاع بان ما يحدث هو خطر على
الجيش
والرئيس الدوله يتحدث عن تفكك الدوله
كل هذه المؤشرات الا يمكن ان تجعل نتنياهو
يراجع موقفه
لا ابدا يعني نتنياهو يعرف انه هذه عباره
عن ضغوط سياسيه تمارس عليه ونحن نعلم
جميعا انه نتنياهو بالنهائي ما يريده هو
عمليا الغاء قوه المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه لتصبح سلطه القضاء بيد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وليس سلطه منفصله عن
الحكمة الاسرائيليه وهذا ما يريده في
النهايه لانه هذا هو حبل النجاه لمصلحه
ولذلك هو يعلم بان هنالك ضغوط سياسيه من
الشارع الاسرائيلي الذي لم يصوت لي
نتنياهو يجب ان نفهم ذلك يعني بشكل واضح
انه القوه التي
تنزل الى الشارع
وتتظاهر ضد السياسه الحكوميه بالنسبه
لزم القضائيه في اسرائيل هي يعني قوه لم
تصوت لاحزام اليمين الاسرائيليه وحتى الان
لم نسمع من اعضاء الركود او غيره الا
اصوات خ هنا او هناك التي تدعي بانه مصلحه
الركود الا يخسر القواعد وحتى الان لم نرى
خساره لمثل هذه القواعد ولذلك هنا فيها
هنالك حرب سياسيه حقيقيه ما بين الاحزاب
المختلفه التي تشكل الحكومه وتلك التي لا
تشكل الحكومه ويستعملون الشارع الان من
اجل الضغط من اجل تحصيل يعني مصالح سياسيه
لهذا الفئه او لشركه الفئه شكرا لك سيد
محمود من الناصره
هذا وقد شهدت العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
مظاهره نظمها اسرائيليون ويهود بريطانيون
امام مقر الحكومه احتجاجا على زياره رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
البريطانيا في الاثناء تنفذ جماعات مؤيده
للفلسطينيين ايضا مظاهره امام مقر الحكومه
البريطانيه للاحتجاج على الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه في حق الشعب الفلسطيني
وكانت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي قد قالت انه
تم الغاء البيان المشترك لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو ونظيره البريطاني
بطلب من لندن وقالت الحكومه البريطانيه ان
سوناك ونتنياهو ناقشات تحديات الامنيه
والدفاعيه المشتركه بما في ذلك حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا والتهديد الذي تشكله ايران
على الاستقرار الاقليمي واضاف البيان ان
سوناك ونتنياهو اتفقا على العمل عن كثب
لصد العدوان واداره مخاطر الانتشار النووي
وبحث سوناك ايضا المخاوف الدوليه من
التوترات المتزايده في الضفه الغربيه وخطر
تقويد الجهود المبذوله لحل الدولتين
معنا من اللانجستر في شمال انجلترا سيمون
مابون استاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص في
شؤون الشرق الاوسط بجامعه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل باتت زيارات نتنياهو الى بعض العواصم
الغربيه غير مرحب بها على الاقل في جزء من
الراي العام
الكثير من الامور تجري هنا فما نشهده حسب
رايكم
هي محاوله لبين لبين يحفظ بدعم دولي وبانه
ما زال يحصل على دعم مستمر من قبل القوى
العظمى مثل المملكه المتحده في مواجهه
عدم ارتياح واحتجاجاتي مستمره من قبل
السكان الاسرائيلين
وضد الموقف الاستبدادي الذي يقوم به
الحكومه وان توسيع الاحتلال والقلق حول
موقف ايران واعتقد انما يحاول يقوم بسيد
نتنياهو هو ان يبين موقفه شخصيا في مثل
هذا الوقت الذي تسوده الكثير من الشك
عندما يقول
بان هناك اهميه لاحترام القيم الديمقراطيه
التي تقوم عليها العلاقه بين البلدين هل
هذه اشاره ضمنيه بعدم ارتياح لندن لكل ما
يجري الان من انقلاب قضائي كما يسمى في
اسرائيل ومن التعامل مع الفلسطينيين
نعم نعم هذا شيء صعب
الحكم عليه فحاليا رئيس الوزراء سوناك
لديه عدد من القضايا
المعاجله التي
ذهنه عليها وفي الوقت الذي انا
معجب
بالمنسوولين في وزاره الخارجيه
اذ يقومون بحفظه بالحث على الاهتمام بما
يحصل في الاراضي المحتله وفي اللذه
الفلسطينيين
وايضا
الاستبداديه الكبيره بدات تسود الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لكن اعتقد الحكومه البريطانيه
نظرا ارتفاع مع تكاليف المعيشه
تغير كبير في داخل الحزب المحافظ من ذلك
اعتقد مع الاسف الوضع فيما يتعلق
بالفلسطينيين بالنسبه لبريطانيا او
الحكومه البريطانيا على الاقل ليست في
جدول اولوياتها وبالتالي هذا طبعا شيء
مخجل ولابد من تصحيح هذا الموقف وهل ايران
في
فكر المسؤولين هناك اولويه تستحق ان تبحث
معنى
انا متاكد بان ايران فعلا في على قمه جدول
اعمال نتنياهو واننا نعلم ان خلال حوالي
30 سنه الماضيه نتنه يدعو الى ويريد ان
يحصل على دعم عام
ومجتمع الدولي وحتى على الساحه الدوليه
كلها هي الدعوه الى ادعموه ضد
تقوم به ايران وضد ايران وشاهدنا ذلك في
اتفاقات ابراهام حيث يحصل على
دعم من دول بعض الدول العربيه بشكل خاص
واعتقد ان الصفقه التي حصلت مؤخرا بين مع
السعوديه
تشير الى تغيير في السياسه الاقليميه وهذا
امر يثير القلق لدى نتنياهو ويسبب قلقا
شديدا بالنسبه للمسؤولين السياسيين في
الزائد وللا يعرفون سيكون موقفهم مع
الولايات المتحده وما يتعلق باعضاء
المنظمين الى اتفاقيه ابراهام
والذين الان سيكون لا يعرفونه
ماذا يفعل الازاء ايران شكرا لك سيما من
انجلترا
حكومه نتنياهو يتزمن مع استمرار تصعيدها
في الضفه الغربيه حيث قالت حركه السلام
الان الاسرائيليه ان الحكومه نكثت بوعودها
في قمه شرم الشيخ الاخيره واعلنت عن
مناقصه لبنائه 940 وحده استيطانيه جديده
جنوب القدس المحتله وذكرت الحركه ان
الحكومه التي وصفتها بالاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل تسعى للقضاء على اي فرصه
لحل الصراع من خلال الانشطه الاستيطانيه
موضحه ان حكومه نتنياهو بهذه الخطوه انما
تعرض العلاقات مع الاداره الامريكيه ودول
صديقه اخرى للخطر وتحول اسرائيل الى دوله
منبوذه لا تفي بعودها حسب وصف حركه السلام
الان
قد اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان
مصادقه الاحتلال على مناقصات لبناء ما
يقارب 940 وحده استيطانيه جديده تعد خلافا
لادعاءات رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه وخروجا
سافرا وتخريبا متعمدا للتفاهمات التي تمت
بين الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
برعايه امريكيه واضاف بيان الوزاره ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقوم بتوسيع وشرعنه
بؤر استيطانيه وتتعامل معها بشكل تضليلي
كانها احياء في مستعمرات كبيره وكانها لن
تقيم مستوطنات جديده واشارت الى ان هذا
يؤكد انها ماضيه في ارتكاب جريمه التوسع
الاستيطاني وتعميق نظام الفصل العنصري
بهدف اغلاق الباب امام اي فرصه لتجديد
الدوله الفلسطينيه على الارض
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا الان حيث قال قائد القوات
البريه الكسنسكي ان قوته ستبدا قريبا
هجوما مضادا في باكموت بعد ان صمدت في وجه
الحمله العسكريه التي شنتها روسيا طوال
الشتاء واكد ان مقاتلي ميليشيا فاجنر
الروسيه يفقدون قدرا كبيرا من قوتهم وان
طاقتهم تنفد في الاثناء افاد موقع ريبارا
العسكريه الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه
مستمره في تطبيق مدينه
وانها تسيطر على مدينه نوفو وذكر الموقع
ان المعارك مستمره في محور بخموت وان قوات
ما زالت تتقدم في المناطق الجنوبيه
لو قد نقلت وكاله عن مسؤولين امريكيين
القول ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد تسعى في
هجومها المرتقب الى قطع الجسر البري الذي
يربط روسيا بشبه جزيره القرم واضافت
الوكاله نقلا عن مسؤولين مطلعين بان
الكرملين يسعى للتعاقد مع 400 الف جندي
هذا العام معظمهم من المحاربين القدامى
وسكان القرى وبحسب تلك المصادر فان حمله
التعاقد الطموحه ستسمح للكرملين بتجنب
التجديد الاجباري مع قرب حمله الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين لاعاده انتخابه
صدق قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي على خطه تهدف
الى تزويد اوكرانيا بمليون قذيفه خلال 12
شهرا وكان وزراء الدفاع والخارجيه
الاوروبيون قد وافقوا قبل ذلك على خطه
بقيمه ملياري يورو لتزويد اوكرانيا بمليون
قذيفه مدفعيه تقتطع من مخزونات دولهم
وقد اكد الرئيس الفرنسي اما نوال المكرمه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيسرع تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره والصواريخ مكروه اضافه في ختام
القمه الاوروبيه في بروكسيل ان القمه جددت
دعمها لاوكرانيا كلما تطلب الامر ذلك
مشيرا الى التجديد على ضروره عدم الافلات
من العقاب لمرتكبي جرائم الحرب
من جانبه قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ان الاسلحه المقدمه الى اوكرانيا
والمتخصصين الاجانب الذين وصلوا معها هدف
مشروع للقوات الروسيه وحذر من ان عواقب
اصطدام اقوى جيوش العالم ستكون رهيبه ولم
يستبعد
ذهاب القوات الروسيه الى كييف او البيف في
اوكرانيا قائلا ان هناك حاجه الى مناطق
منزوعه السلاح حول المناطق التي سيطرت
عليها القوات الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
انا مجلس منسقيه مشروع سد النهضه في
اثيوبيا ان 90% من بناء السد قد اكتمل
وقالت نائبه رئيس المجلس فقرت تامروا ان
سد النهضه واجه التحديات وضغوطا دبلوماسيه
وحربا داخليه ومع ذلك تمكن الاثيوبيون من
انجازه وكان وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري قد اكد في تصريحا سابق ان كل
الخيارات والبدائل متاحه امام بلاده
للدفاع عن مقدرتها ومصالح شعبها مشددا على
اهميه التوصل الى اتفاق قانونيا ملزم
لتشغيل وملا السد الاثيوبي
مره اخرى تعود قضيه سد النهضه الى واجهه
الاحداث في اثيوبيا والسودان ومصر
السلطات الاثيوبيه اعلنت اكتمال تسعين في
المئه من بناء السد رغم ما وصفته
بالتحديات والضغوط الدبلوماسيه التي
واجهتها وحرب التجرايه الداخليه التي
عرقلت عددا من منشات البنى التحتيه في
اثيوبيا
اديس ابابا اعلنت عزمها الاحتفال يوم
السبت بالذكرى الثانيه عشره لوضع حجر
الاساس للسد وتستعد لعمليات تعبئته
الرابعه في يوليو القادم بينما لا تزال
خلافاتها مع الخرطوم والقاهره قائمه وقد
فشلت مفاوضات العواصم الثلاثه في الوصول
لحل رغم انعقاد عشرات الجلسات بواساطات
دوليه واقليميه
الاعلان الاثيوبي جاء رغم تحذير وزير الري
المصري هاني السويلم في الامم المتحده بان
استمرار عمليه البناء والتعبئه والشروع في
تشغيل سد النهضه بشكل احادي خرق للقانون
الدولي ويمكن ان يشكلها على حد تعبيره
خطرا وجوديا وكارثيا على نحو 150 مليون
شخص وكانت اثيوبيا قد رفضت بشده تصريحات
لوزير الخريه المصري سامح شكري اكد فيها
ان كل الخيارات والبدائل متاحه امام مصر
للدفاع عن مقدراتها ومصالح شعبها ورغم ان
الاتحاد الافريقي فشل وعبر عده جولات في
تقريب وجهات نظر الجاربين فان الحديث يدور
من جديد عن ضروره تدخله والدعوه لجوله
مفاوضات جديده وبسرعه بغيت الوصول الى
اتفاق بين الدول الثلاث قبل بدايه التعبئه
الرابعه
ذلك الاتفاق الذي بدا عصيا حتى الان حيث
تتمسك اثيوبيا باتفاقيه اعلان المبادئ
الموقعه في الخرطوم في مارس عام 2015
بينما تصفها مصر بانها كانت تعبيرا عن حسن
نيه لم يقابل بالمرونه المطلوبه من
اثيوبيا بل تطالب اثيوبيا كذلك باعاده
تقسيم حصص مياه النيل بينها وبين مصر
والسودان وهو الموضوع الذي ترفضه الخرطوم
والقاهره وتقولان ان امره حسم منذ عقود
وفي اثارته تعقيد لا علاقه له بموضوع سد
النهضه
مرحبا
من موقع رئيس الوزراء الدكتور ابي احمد
باعتبار انه انتصر في حرب التقراي وهو
الان
يستغل
يعني قضيه سد النهضه ايضا للترويج لانتصار
اخر له على المستوى الاقليمي
عندما تقول مصر بان كل الخيارات متاحه
امامها نظرا للضرر الكبيره الذي سيلحقها
كما تقول ماذا بقي لديها من خيارات حقيقه
الحقيقه يعني مثل هذا التعبير تكرر اكثر
من مره على السنه مسؤوليه مصريين لكن عاده
ما يؤخذ على انه بمعنى الحل العسكري
واعتقد ان البديل العسكري بالنسبه للقاهره
الان غير ممكن
بالنظر للعديد من الاعتبارات بنظر الوضع
الاقتصادي الان هل تتحمل القاهره الدخول
في مثل هذه الحرب بالنظر الى فيتو دولي
على اي يعني توتر جديد في منطقه يعني
متصدعه
بالاضافه الى اعتبارات اخرى كما ذكرت
فالخيارات التي تبقت امام القاهره
الحقيقيه خيارات ضيقه وخيارات ممكن ان
نقسمها الى جزئين جزء مرتبط بالخارج من
خلال محاوله حشد ضغوط دوليه من اطراف
قادره على الضغط على اثيوبيا يعني ما
شاهدناه خلال السنوات الماضيه انه لم يكن
هناك ضغط جدي على اثيوبيا لو كان هناك ضغط
جدي على اثيوبيا ربما كان الم فاخذ شكل
اخر فلننظر الى حرب التقراي
اتفاقيه بريكتوريا مورثه ضغوط كبيره على
اثيوبيا وعلى الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير وفي
النهايه الحكومه الاثيوبيه تجاوبت وتم
توقيع الاتفاق اذا كان من الممكن ممارسه
هذا النوع من الضغوط ايضا على الحكومه
الاثيوبيه لكن يبدو انه لا الاطراف
المعنيه اقليميا او دوليا لها رغبه او
مصلحه في مثل هذه الضغوط وبالتالي
ما تستطيع مصر ان تفعله الان هو محاوله
تحريك مواقف هذه الدول محاوله حشد القوى
العربيه ذات الاستثمارات الكبيره في في
اثيوبيا كسعوديه والامارات ربما يكون تكون
لها قدره على
الضغط قدرا ما او نوعا ما على الحكومه
الاثيوبيه كذلك لاحظنا خلال السنوات
الاخيره توجه كبير من القاهره نحو تمتين
العلاقات مع على اكثر من صعيد مع دول حوض
النيل لكن الاشكال في مثل هذا النوع من
محاوله الاستفاده من هذه العلاقات ان بعض
هذه الدول هي تريد الاستفاده ايضا بالمسد
النهضه وبالتالي القاهره لابد ان تقدم لها
بديل مقنع بديل مقنع عن تستطيع من خلالي
ان هذه الدول ان تمارس نوع من الضغوط على
اثيوبيا
بالنسبه للداخل طبعا الخيار المتبقي لمصر
هو محاوله ترشيد الاستهلاك يعني اتخاذ
اجراءات في هذا الخصوص شكرا جزيلا لك يا
عبد القادر محمد علي من تورنتو
اثرت موجه الجفاف التي تضرب منطقه بورونا
الجنوبيه اثيوبيا على نمط عيش المجتمعات
الرعويه وفقا لاداره المنطقه فان اكثر من
800 الف شخص يحتاجون لمساعدات عاجله وذلك
بعد نفوق مواشيهم التي كانوا يعتمدون
عليها في تامين قوتهم وقد حست منظمات
انسانيه الحكومه الاثيوبيه والمجتمع
الدولي على ضروره تقديم الدعم الفوري
للسكان لمواجهه اضرار الجفاف
في بيئه الجفاف السائده في منطقه بورونا
جنوب اثيوبيا تبدا لوجو يومها بانتظار
الاستسقاء
فالشاحنات باتت مصدر المياه الوحيد تجد
لوجو نفسها وحيده مع ابنائها في مغالبه
ظروف الحياه فزوجها سافر بحثا عن عمل بعد
نفوق مواشيه النساء والاطفال في ظل الجفاف
هم اكثر الشرائح تضررا
الماء لا يكفينا نحتاج الى المزيد
فالحراره مرتفعه جدا كثيرون غادروا وقد
نضطروا الى الالتحاق بهم اذا استمر الجفاف
شحاتت الامطار فالحسره المساحات الرعويه
فنفقت ملايين رؤوس الماشيه وما بقي منها
يتهدده الهزال والمرض وقد انخفضت اسعارها
بسبب ذلك لكنها كارثه لمجتمع يعتمد عليها
مصدرا وحيدا للدخل من ثم
المواشيش على السكان معدمين ما اثر على
غذائهم وصحتهم لقد دمجنا اربع بلدات في
بلده واحده لنساعدهم بالامكانات المتاحه
لدينا وهي قليله مقارنه بحجم المعاناه
الالاف غادروا مناطقهم بحثا عن سبل للحياه
مخيم دبلقي احد عشره مخيمات مؤقته انشات
لاستقبال مئات الاف النازحين
كنت ميسور الحال واملك عشرات الابقار الان
اصبحت عاله على الاخرين ترك ابناء مدارسهم
اعرفوا اشخاصا ماتوا حسره على اوضاعهم
نحتاج الى دعم عاجل والى حلول لمعاناتنا
موجه الجفاف هذه انها الاسوا في اثيوبيا
منذ اربعين عاما نظرا الى شدتها وطول
مدتها وحجم الاضرار التي سببتها تشير
التوقعات المناخيه الى استمرار الجفاف حتى
منتصف هذا العام وهو ما ينظر بعواقب وخيمه
على المنطقه وسكانها وتدعو المنظمات
الاغاثيه الى تقديم مساعدات والمساهمه في
توفير حلول جذريه لدعم الرعاه وانقاذ ما
تبقى من الثروه الحيوانيه
حسن الرزاق الجزيره من منطقه بورونا
جنوبيه اثيوبيا
[موسيقى]
لليوم الثاني على التوالي يشهد بحر جنوب
الصين توترا ملاحيا فقد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه انها طرق مجددا اليوم
الجمعه لمراقبه وابعاد المدمره الامريكيه
التي دخلت ما قالت بجين انها مياهها
الاقليميه قرب جزر براسيل بعد ان كانت
وجهت لها يوم امس تحذيرات وطلبتها بضروره
الابتعاد وزاره الدفاع السينيه اضافت انها
تطلب او تطالب الولايات المتحده بحزم
بضروره التوقف على الفور عما وصفاتها
بالافعال الاستفزازيه والا فان واشنطن
تتحمل التداعيات الخطيره لهذه الحوادث غير
المتوقعه وفق بيان الوزراء
هذا وترجح تقارير وتحليلات عالميه ان يكون
بحر جنوب الصين هو اخطر واكثر مكان محتمل
لمواجهه عسكريه مباشره بين الولايات
المتحده والصين فبينما تؤكد بجين على ان
البحر جزء من اراضيها وبحارها الداخليه
تصر واشنطن ومعها دول اخرى في المنطقه مثل
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان والفلبين وفيتنام
وغيرها على اعتبار هذا البحر ممرا بلا حيا
دوليا مفتوحا وتطالب الفلبين وفيتنام
وماليزيا وبروناي باجزاء من هذا البحر
بينما ترسل الولايات المتحده سفنا تابعه
لبحريتها للتاكيد على حريه الملاحه في
مياه دوليه
احتمال وقوع مواجهه خطيره تم تجنبه حتى
الان بين السفن الحربيه الصينيه
والامريكيه التي تتحرك بكثافه في هذه
المنطقه في حين يحذر الجيش الصيني
باستمرار من تحليق الطائرات الامريكيه فوق
قطاعه البحريه ويخشى المراقبون شبح وقوع
حادث يمكن ان يؤدي الى مواجهه عسكريه اكبر
بين البلدين العملاقين على غرار المواجهه
التي تمت خلال الحرب الكوريه في خمسينات
القرن الماضي
بحر جنوب الصين واحد من اهم الطرق
الملاحيه التجاريه
حيويه في العالم وهو كذلك واحد من
الشرايين التجاريه الرئيسيه التي تجمع
الممرات المائيه من كل من سنغافوره
وماليزيا ووفقا لبيانات صدرت عن مؤتمر
الامم المتحده للتجاره والتنميه فان نحو
21% من اجماليه تجاره العالميه والتي تقدر
قيمتها بثلاثه فاصل 37 تريليون دولار قد
مرت عبر البحر في عام 2016
وبخلاف الصين هناك خمس دول تعتمد بشكل
كبير على حركه الملاحه هناك لنرى هذه
الدول فيتنام فيتنام التي شهدت نموا
اقتصاديا كبيرا ليصل قيمه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للبلاد الى اكثر من 360 مليار
دولار عام
2021 ثم هناك ايضا سنغافوره الذي يعتبر
مضيقها ممرا رئيسيا للبضائع نحو اوروبا
والامريكيتين وهو مضيق يمتد بطول
155 كيلومترات ويشهد مرور نحو الف سفينه
يوميا
هناك ايضا اندونيسيا حيث يعتبر تعتبر
مضيقه سوناد او عفوا سوندا من البوابات
الرئيسيه لبحر جنوب الصين وهناك اليابان
التي يمر نحو 42% من تجارتها البحريه عبر
هذا البحر اخيرا هناك كوريا الجنوبيه وهي
رابعه اقتصاد اكبر اقتصاد اسيوي حيث يقدر
ناتجها المحلي الاجمالي بنحو واحد فاصل
ثمانيه تريليون دولار عام 2021 ويعتمد
بشكل كبير استيراد الطاقه التي يمر اغلبها
عبر البحر
معنى الان من صوفيا
استاذ الدراسات الاسيويه بجامعه نابولي
والباحث في مشروع الصين بجامعه تورين
الايطاليه اهلا وسهلا بك
ان تكون هناك دول عديده معنيه بهذا البحر
مثلما تابعنا هل يخفف من احتمال التصادم
الصيني الامريكي هناك
وشكرا لدعوتي كما قلتم
فان تواجد عده اطراف وعده مصالح مختلفه في
المنطقه يخفف الى حد ما امكانيه تصادم قوي
بين الصين والولايات المتحده ولكن اتفق مع
مؤخرخين ومحللين اخرين
يقارنوا
البحر الجنوب الصين في
بالبلقان في القرن العشرين اي كانه
انه كانه قنبله موقوته يمكن ان تنفجر اذا
ما حصل اي توترات مما قد يسبب حربا عالميه
لكن حاليا نحن ننتظر لنرى ان نرى هذه
حوادث الصغيره
وما اجده مهما انا كمرق هو انظر كيف ان
البلدين المعنيين الصين والولايات المتحده
يستخدمان خطابين مختلفين وارائم مختلفه
لتبرير
استراتيجيتهما في المنطقه وهذا لذلك انا
ارى ان هناك اجنده تنافسيه في بحر جنوب
الصين لاعاده تعريف نظام عالمي جديد
للعقود القادمه حتى العقود القرون القديمه
الولايات المتحده ارتدت تدعي بان لديه
حريه ملاحه ولكن من جانب اخر هناك ادعات
حول السياده الوطنيه من قبل الصين
واتهامات للولايات المتحده بانها
تنتهك انها
انها تستخدم هم هذا الطريقه اللي فرض
هيمنتها على المنطقه وهذا الشيء موجود
رائجا وسنشهده في المستقبل بشكل اكثر وهو
يبين لنا مدى الفرق الكبير بين اجنده
الولايات المتحده من جانب وجنده الصين من
جانب اخر ولكن هذه الحوادث الصغيره كما
سميتها
ما الذي يحول دون ان تتحول الى الى حوادث
كبرى وخطيره جدا في المنطقه
ان شخصيا لا اعتقد اننا سنجد اي شيء من
هذا القبيل حتى في السنوات القادمه
العالم الان يشعر بقلق حول ما يحصل في
اوكرانيا ولا يهتمون بالصين وليس مصلحه
الصين ولا مصلحه الولايات المتحده في
مواجهه مباشره اعتقد اولا عليه ان نرى كيف
ستتطور الموقف في اوكرانيا واذا ما انتهت
هذه الحرب في وقت ما قريب فسيشهد نظاما
جديدا سيظهر والصين ستقوم بدور جديد عن
ذاك سيكون بالتاكيد له تاثيرات وتبعات على
التوترات الحاليه في بحر جنوب الصين
وموضوع التايوان ولكن بالنسبه لوقت الحالي
اعتقد اننا فقط سنشهد مثل هذه المصادمات
الخلافات البسيطه ولكن كما قلت انتم ان
التاريخ ليس علم ليس رياضيات وبالتالي
فالكثير من التوقعات
غالبا ما
يثبت خطائها وكما حصل فيما يتعلق غزو
اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال وبالتالي لا
نستطيع استبعاد مع الاسف انه شيء ما قد
يحصل ويتصاعد ولكن اولا عليه ننظر الى
الموقف فيه اوكرانيا ثم سنرى موضوع بحر
جنوب الصين سيصبح اكثره كميه سيد
عن مصادر مطلعه تقول بان الجانب الصيني لم
يستجب بعد لطلبات الولايات المتحده لاجراء
مكالمه بين رئيسي البلدين
غياب الاتصال السياسي بين القيادتين هل
يمكن ان يعقد
الاشكال القائم حاليا في بحر الصين
نعم بالتاكيد ومره اخرى اقول هذا كله جزء
من اللعبه اكبر
نشهدها وهي تشمل الحرب في اوكرانيا
والدول تقوم به الصين او قد تقوم فيه
بالمستقبل ولكن مع لو قارنا نوعيته كميه
الاتصالات بين الادارتين في بيتين واشنطن
فقبل عشر كنا معتادين ان نرى كانت صوره
قادمه مقلقه ولكن شاهدنا جانبين نجد ان
خطاب او نظره الحرب البارده الجديده بدات
تشدد وتظهر وان ذلك سيكون له تاثيرات
وسنعلك ان ينفككه اسطور هذا الامر وكيف
سيظهر كل بلد الى الاخر ليس هناك ما يدعو
للتفاؤل حول تطورات العلاقه بين الولايات
المتحده والصين ولكن في الوقت ذاته كما
قلت نستطيع ان نعمل انه لا يكون هناك اي
تصادم عسكري مباشر
بينهما في المستقبل شكرا جزيلا لك السيد
بروستد
من صوفيا
بهذا المشاهدين الكرام نكونوا قد وصلنا
الى نهايه جوله الحصاد الحصاد الليله في
امان الله
[موسيقى]